We know that when we have some
substance in a liquid state,
it has enough kinetic energy for
the molecules to move past
each other, but still not
enough energy for the
molecules to completely move
away from each other.
So, for example, this
is a liquid.
Maybe they're moving
in that direction.
These guys are moving a little
bit slower in that direction
so there's a bit of this flow
going on, but still there are
bonds between them.
They kind of switch between
different molecules, but they
want to stay close
to each other.
There are these little bonds
between them and they want to
stay close.
If you increase the average
kinetic energy enough, or
essentially increase the
temperature enough and then
overcome the heat of fusion, we
know that, all of a sudden,
even these bonds aren't strong
enough to even keep them
close, and the molecules
separate and they get into a
gaseous phase.
And there they have a lot of
kinetic energy, and they're
bouncing around, and they take
the shape of their container.
But there's an interesting
thing to think about.
Temperature is average
kinetic energy.
Which implies, and it's true,
that all of the molecules do
not have the same
kinetic energy.
Let's say even they did.
Then these guys would bump into
this guy, and you could
think of them as billiard balls,
and they transfer all
of the momentum to this guy.
Now this guy has a ton
of kinetic energy.
These guys have a lot less.
This guy has a ton.
There's a huge distribution
of kinetic energy.
If you look at the surface
atoms or the surface
molecules, and I care about the
surface molecules because
those are the first ones
to vaporize or-- I
shouldn't jump the gun.
They're the ones capable of
leaving if they had enough
kinetic energy.
If I were to draw a distribution
of the surface
molecules-- let me draw
a little graph here.
So in this dimension, I have
kinetic energy, and on this
dimension, this is just a
relative concentration.
And this is just my best
estimate, but it should give
you the idea.
So there's some average
kinetic energy at some
temperature, right?
This is the average
kinetic energy.
And then the kinetic energy of
all the parts, it's going to
be a distribution around that,
so maybe it looks something
like this: a bell curve.
You could watch the statistics
videos to learn more about the
normal distribution, but
I think the normal
distribution-- this is supposed
to be a normal, so it
just gets smaller and smaller
as you go there.
And so at any given time,
although the average is here,
there's some molecules
that have a
very low kinetic energy.
They're moving slowly or maybe
they have-- well, let's just
say they're moving slowly.
And at any given time, you have
some molecules that have
a very high kinetic energy,
maybe just because of the
random bumps that it gets
from other molecules.
It's accrued a lot of velocity
or at least a lot of momentum.
So the question arises,
are any of these
molecules fast enough?
Do they have enough kinetic
energy to escape?
And so there is some
kinetic energy.
I'll draw some threshold here,
where if you have more than
that amount of kinetic energy,
you actually have enough to
escape if you are
surface atom.
Now, there could be a dude down
here who has a ton of
kinetic energy.
But in order for him to escape,
he'd have to bump
through all these other liquid
molecules on the way out, so
it's a very-- in fact, he
probably won't escape.
It's the surface atoms that we
care about because those are
the ones that are interfacing
directly with
the pressure outside.
So let's say this is
the gas outside.
It's going to be much
less dense.
It doesn't have to be, but
let's assume it is.
These are the guys that kind
of can escape into the air
above it, if we assume that
there's some air above it.
So at any given time, there's
some fraction of the particles
or the molecules that
can escape.
So you're next question is, hey,
well, doesn't that mean
that they will be vaporized or
they will turn into gas?
And yes, it does.
So at any given time,
you have some
molecules that are escaping.
Those molecules-- what it's
called is evaporation.
This isn't a foreign
concept to you.
If you leave water outside, it
will evaporate, even though
outside, hopefully, in your
place, is below the boiling
temperature, or the normal
boiling temperature of water.
The normal boiling point is
just the boiling point at
atmospheric pressure.
If you just leave water out,
over time, it will evaporate.
What happens is some of these
molecules that have unusually
high kinetic energy do escape.
They do escape, and if you have
your pot or pan outside
or, even better, outside of your
house, what happens is
they escape, and then
the wind blows.
The wind will blow and then
blow these guys away.
And then a few more will escape,
the wind blows and
blows them all away.
And a few more escape, and
the wind blows and blows
them all the way.
So over time, you'll end up with
an empty pan that once
held water.
Now, the question is
what happens if you
have a closed system?
Well, we've all done that
experiment, either on purpose
or inadvertently, leaving
something outside and seeing
that the water will evaporate.
What happens in a closed system
where there isn't wind
to blow away?
So let me just draw--
there you go.
Let's say a closed system, and I
have-- it doesn't have to be
water, but I have some
liquid down here.
And there's some pressure
from the air above it.
Let's just say it was at
atmospheric pressure.
It doesn't have to be.
So there's some air and
the air has some
kinetic energy over here.
So, of course, do the
water molecules.
And some of them start
to evaporate.
So some of the water molecules
that are up here in the
distribution, they have enough
energy to escape, so they
start hanging out with the
air molecules, right?
Now something interesting
happens.
This is the distribution
of the molecules
in the liquid state.
Well, there's also a
distribution of the kinetic
energies of the molecules
in the gaseous state.
Just like different things are
bumping into each other and
gaining and losing kinetic
energy down here, the same
thing is happening up here.
So maybe this guy has a lot of
kinetic energy, but he bumps
into stuff and he loses it.
And then he'll come back down.
So there's some set
of molecules.
I'll do it in another
set of blue.
These are still the water-- or
whatever the fluid we're
talking about-- that come back
from the vapor state back into
the liquid state.
And so what happens is, there's
always a bit of
evaporation and there's always
a bit of condensation because
you always have this
distribution of kinetic energies.
At any given moment in time,
out of the vapor above the
liquid, some of the vapor loses
its kinetic energy and
then it goes back into
the liquid state.
Some of the surface liquid gains
kinetic energy by random
bumps and whatever else and
goes into the vapor state.
And the vapor state will
continue to happen until you
get to some type
of equilibrium.
And when you get that
equilibrium, we're at some
pressure up here.
So let me see, some pressure.
And the pressure is caused by
these vapor particles over
here, and that pressure is
called the vapor pressure.
I want to make sure you
understand this.
So the vapor pressure is the
pressure created, and this is
at a given temperature for
a given molecule, right?
Every molecule or every type
of substance will have a
different vapor pressure at
different temperatures, and
obviously every different type
of substance will also have
different vapor pressures.
For a given temperature and
a given molecule, it's the
pressure at which you have a
pressure created by the vapor
molecules where you have
an equilibrium.
Where you have just as many
things vaporizing as things
going back into the
liquid state.
And we learned before that the
more pressure you have, the
harder it is to vaporize
even more, right?
We learned in the phase state
things that if you are at 100
degrees at ultra-high pressure,
and you were dealing
with water, you would still
be in the liquid state.
So the vapor creates some
pressure and it'll keep
happening, depending
on how badly this
liquid wants to evaporate.
But it keeps vaporizing until
the point that you have just
as much-- I guess you could kind
of view it as density up
here, but I don't want to
think-- you have just as many
molecules here converting into
this state as molecules here
converting into this state.
So just to get an intuition of
what vapor pressure is or how
it goes with different
molecules, molecules that
really want to evaporate-- and
so why would a molecule want
to evaporate?
It could have high kinetic
energy, so this would be at a
high temperature.
It could have low intermolecular
forces, right?
It could be molecular.
Obviously, the noble gases
have very low molecular
forces, but in general, most
hydrocarbons or gasoline or
methane or all of these things,
they really want to
evaporate because they have
much lower intermolecular
forces than, say, water.
Or they could just be
light molecules.
You could look at the physics
lectures, but kinetic energy
it's a function of mass
and velocity.
So you could have a pretty
respectable kinetic energy
because you have a high mass
and a low velocity.
So if you have a light mass and
the same kinetic energy,
you're more likely to have
a higher velocity.
You could watch the kinetic
energy videos for that.
But something that wants to
evaporate, a lot of its
molecules-- let me do it
in a different color.
Something that wants to
evaporate really bad, a lot
more of its molecules will have
to enter into this vapor
state in order for the
equilibrium to be reached.
Let me do it all in
the same color.
So the pressure created by its
evaporated molecules is going
to be higher for it to get to
that equilibrium state, so it
has high vapor pressure.
And on the other side, if you're
at a low temperature or
you have strong intermolecular
forces or you have a heavy
molecule, then you're going to
have a low vapor pressure.
For example, iron has a very
low vapor pressure because
it's not vaporizing while--
let me think of something.
Carbon dioxide has
a relatively much
higher vapor pressure.
Much more of carbon dioxide
is going to evaporate
when you have it.
Well, I really shouldn't use
that because you're going
straight from the liquid to the
solid state, but I think
you get the idea.
And something that has a high
vapor pressure, that wants to
evaporate really bad, we say
it has a high volatility.
You've probably heard
that word before.
So, for example, gasoline has a
higher-- it's more volatile
than water, and that's why it
evaporates, and it also has a
higher vapor pressure.
Because if you were to put it
in a closed container, more
gasoline at the same temperature
and the same
atmospheric pressure, will enter
into the vapor state.
And so that vapor state will
generate more pressure to
offset the natural inclination
of the gasoline to want to
escape than in the
case with water.
Now, an interesting thing
happens when this vapor
pressure is equal to the
atmospheric pressure.
So right now, this is our closed
container and you have
the atmosphere here at
a certain pressure.
Let's say until now, we've
assumed that the atmosphere
was at a higher pressure, for
the most part keeping these
molecules contained.
Maybe some atmosphere molecules
are coming in here,
and maybe some of the vapor
molecules are escaping a bit,
but it's keeping it contained
because this is at a higher
pressure out here than
this vapor pressure.
And of course the pressure right
here, at the surface of
the molecule, is going to be the
combination of the partial
pressure due to the few
atmospheric molecules that
come in, plus the
vapor pressure.
But once that vapor pressure
becomes equal to that
atmospheric pressure, so it can
press out with the same
amount of force-- you can kind
of view it as force per area--
so then the molecules
can start to escape.
It can push the atmosphere
back.
And so you start having
a gap here.
You start having a vacuum.
I don't want to use exactly
a vacuum, but since the
molecules escaped, more and more
of these molecules can
start going out.
And at that point, you've
reached the boiling point of
the substance when the vapor
pressure is equal to the
atmospheric pressure.
Just to get a sense of what all
of this means, let's look
at the vapor pressure
for water.
This is water right here, H2O.
I should do that in black.
And so you see at 760-- so
atmospheric pressure, we're in
torr now, but that's just a
different-- 760 torr is equal
to 1 atmosphere, so that's
about right.
That's about right there,
so it's 1 atmosphere.
So at atmospheric pressure,
the vapor pressure at 100
degrees Celsius for water-- the
vapor is at 100 degrees
Celsius for water.
Or I guess another way to put
it, at 100 degrees Celsius,
you have 760 torr of vapor
pressure, which is exactly the
atmospheric pressure, or 1
atmosphere, at sea level.
So at 100 degrees, vapor
pressure is equal to
atmospheric, or sea
level atmospheric.
And so you're going to boil,
which we all know is true.
And then at lower temperatures,
your vapor
pressure is going to
be lower than the
atmospheric pressure, right?
Let's see, here it looks
like 300 something.
But then what happens?
If you lowered the atmospheric
pressure enough, if you were
to pump air out of the
container, or whatever, low
enough, so if you brought the
atmospheric pressure down to
this vapor pressure, then again,
you will have boiling.
And we saw that in the phase
change diagrams, that you can
boil something at a lower
temperature if you lower the
atmospheric pressure.
And that's because you're
lowering the atmospheric
pressure to the vapor pressure
of the substance.
And here's a comparative
chart, and this is
interesting.
You see this is kind of an
exponential increase with
temperature of vapor pressure.
And that's because, if you think
about that distribution
we did before, this is at
one kinetic energy.
If you increase the amount of
kinetic energy, then your
distribution will
look like this.
The temperature has gone up.
And now you have a
lot, lot more.
It's not just linear.
You have a lot more particles
that can now escape and have
the kinetic energy
to evaporate.
And you can see it's this
exponential increase as you
increase the temperature.
Now, here's another chart.
You say, hey, where's that
exponential increase going?
That's because this is
a logarithmic chart.
You can see the scale.
It increases exponentially as
opposed to linearly, so it
goes from 0.1 to 10, so equal
distances are actually up by a
factor of 10, so that's
why you don't see
that logarithmic move.
But these are just for
different substances.
Propane, you see at any given--
so let's go at like a
decent temperature.
Let's go 20 degrees Celsius.
At 20 Celsius, propane has the
highest vapor pressure.
So this is 1 atmosphere, so
propane will actually
evaporate, will actually boil
at 20 degrees Celsius.
It will actually completely
boil and go
into the gaseous state.
Because its vapor pressure
is so much higher than
atmospheric pressure, if we're
assuming we're at sea level.
And you could do that for
different molecules.
Methyl chloride is
the next one.
It's a slightly lower
vapor pressure,
but still very volatile.
It would still definitely boil
and turn into the gaseous
state at 20 degrees Celsius if
we're at sea level because sea
level is right there.
Let's see, at sea level, if you
wanted to keep something--
so sea level is this pressure--
if you wanted to
keep let's say, methyl
chloride.
If you wanted to keep methyl
chloride in the liquid state,
or in equilibrium with the
liquid state instead of
boiling, you would have
to be at least at
around-- what is this?
Minus 25 degrees Celsius
in order for that.
Propane, even at minus 25
degrees is still in the
gaseous state because its vapor
pressure is still higher.
And then, of course, if you
have butane, for example.
Butane I think is what they put
in lighters, but butane
will be in the liquid state as
long as you're at around
roughly 0 degrees.
In a lighter, you might say,
oh, it's in a liquid state.
They probably increase the
pressure so the pressure in
the lighter is probably
something higher.
Maybe it's at 2 atmospheres or
something, so that the butane
at room temperature will stay
in the liquid state.
Who knows?
I don't know what the pressure
is in there.
This is just an interesting
chart to look at, that there's
actually a bunch of different
vapor pressures.
You can see at atmospheric
pressure what's likely to be a
gas or a liquid at different
temperatures, and then you
could see at different
temperatures, which are the
things that are most volatile
and how much do you have to
increase or decrease the
pressure to evaporate
something or to boil it.
Anyway, hopefully you
found that useful.
Vapor pressure is something that
we encounter every day,
and I'll see you in
the next video.